nous sommes à un tournant de notre histoire
comme vous le savez il y a un
manque de respect croissant pour le gouvernement c'est une crise
de confiance nous pouvons voir cette crise dans
le doute croissant sur le sens de
nos propres vies et dans la perte d'une unité
de but  pour notre nation
nous avons toujours cru que nous faisions partie d'
un grand mouvement de l'humanité elle-même
impliquée dans la recherche de la liberté nous avons
toujours cru que les jours de nos
enfants seraient meilleurs que les nôtres
mais nous avons découvert que seuls les voleurs
et les consommateurs  les choses ne satisfont pas
notre désir de sens wow il est tellement
foutu c'est fini pour lui je pensais que
c'était beau
arrête de
penser que tu sais que tout se
passe non je pense juste que tu
sais qu'avoir le cœur brisé est une
formidable façon d'apprendre  à propos du monde,
je vois les formes
[Musique]
Je dirai que c'est sûr que c'est la
partie vraiment difficile et ça
s'améliore et puis ça redevient difficile Jésus tu es
heureux
sérieusement regarde en te demandant si tu es
heureux  ortcut juste d'être
déprimé
[Musique]